la numero 20 permettete a roma voi forse
non lo sapete ma io a montici vissuto
per cinque ore
ho fatto una spesa sono andato dalla
voglia di amici alcuni purtroppo visti
andare via
diciamo che tra introdotto io introdotto
a monte ed è un piacere tornare con te a
monti insieme anche a queste ragazze
alle quali stiamo facendo scoprire un pò
che non una roma che non conoscono 20
curdo levati curdo punto non mi fissava
a casa bisogna te le scarpe perché
athena roma ho appena trovato la
fidanzata che nella tanto che il modo
sud odorare mara le curve ci prova ci
prova ci trova l ora sta bene
buda lei è una ragazza indipendente
vedete vedete che ha fatto un passo
avanti scuse sfilando contenta perché
appena ci provi ti va bene
ecco che non è bisogno di un uomo
bravata uno schiaffo abbiamo lasciato da
marco enrico a casa con la playstation
avevo detto divertitevi
noi siamo fuggiti io credo che sia la
prima volta nella quale forse valentina
vede la luce del sole meraviglioso come
vedi io mi permetto del girare col
cappello di natale in casa mia versione
mondo vanta canto che ci consigli di
andare il sorrento che vuoi fare
aperitivi
non so se non tutto vuol capire
non è giusto dell'aperitivo e madre di
bagni c'è un profumo tipo di pan di
zenzero è un profumo di casa mia mi
piace l'odore di casa tua non ci sediamo
con di amor mio amico che unico cose ma
c'è chi sta facendo si chiama perché
dobbiamo del contromano era contromano
mio le visite riaperto luglio gabriele
scilla
hai capito con chi stai parlando farci
trovare un posto comodo per quattro no
non vivo più qui ma sta fingendo di
produzione tramite lettere così storia
sicuramente parlando al telefono con
l'amico diamo a chiamarlo lo chiamiamo
valenti cio scusa ti devo attaccare che
c'è la chiamata solo scusa al disturbo
gabriele o dicevi siamo arrivava da sono
quasi arrivato dal solito al posto al
tombino all'altezza del tombino con
ritorni il bambino perché un anno
passato a tombino al furgone bianco mi
sono subito dopo il furgone via esatto
prima della focus lavoro station ci
siamo quasi
vabbè oprah fuoco a parte che non ho
capito questo colpo di testa che cosa
vuoi fare di paris hilton dirlo il cane
si porta così no ha capito ha capito che
stavo io sono molto contento
ma quante ne conti ne abbiamo passate
prima altri ricordi penso siamo allenati
tanto insieme i due lui posso dire che
non è assolutamente un orario consono
per andare a fare un aperitivo
quindi non ho capito perché mi sto
facendo trascinare dalla follia di
gabriele che ci vuole somministrare un
aperitivo che c'è un attimo sta
situazione questa si chiama a pagare
però la porta di bravo vedi la vicina di
casa certo il male viene serpenti e
possiamo notare uno scorcio lo porto io
ve lo portò via
andiamo da mariuccia non è pericoloso
però siete brave coincidenza con tutti e
tutti ti amano dei quartiere se capisce
che ancora la prima di questa miglia dal
mio amico più del locale che vediamo
tutti i giorni non è che ci si deve tra
l'altro voglio dire io posso permettermi
quale rione fi
ecco la guida come sai ma federico
aspettava ma lo sai che è un amico ma
non sto mettendo fraterno proprio
immagino io sono caprile e lui e sud
venite prima fate come faccio a caso di
altri è un posto magnifico anche adesso
un posto magnifico federico fanno dei
coppie pazzeschi ma è la base che prima
non ammettere nel video che più di
qualcuno tirava ci sono stata con man
che vivete sotto ci sono stata e
federico devo dire in questo ogni volta
che mi ha visto con una diversa qui
faccia da poker sempre a ciao piacere
non è sempre così solo e grande dame
grande io curiosa un ristorante che mi
fa sempre grande perché avete sempre
solo con le sue amiche nota federico
puoi togliere puoi togliere a casa i
ragazzi inquadrature pazzesche comunque
sta facendo webber e averla le chiamo
chiamo una casa madre un'altra parte li
chiamò a caso a tutte voi che dite che
figura brera questo qui è la
testimonianza per farvi capire che tra
sono sufficientemente avete come si sta
sempre bene hanno un bellissimo ricordo
sempre meno povero sia di quello mentale
anche a livello sessuale di divertimento
giusto
io l'ho lasciato che ancora la pena di
danza e adesso lo ritrovo master scherma
ma è piena ma cazzate
caso tutti buggiano e vero e proprio che
spara solo che c'è solo cazzate sparate
quindi in realtà cabrei tipo b xix c'era
un tocco di vedere mai conosciuto anche
le gemelle quelle con due teste male ma
scusate fatto che ti si è travestita
vale per riuscire rossetto viola non
esco da casa da settimane la mobilità il
mio lamentata d'aria fresca decido di
grafico cosa bevi vediamo questo guarda
un po te lo ricordi quindi harbin è
stato un giorno fantastico quel giorno
ricordi il tavolo quale tu che posizione
era questo perché se non sbaglio cioè
socialismo molti conte infatti erano in
fila e all'ultimo qualcuno non lo vedo
qui era di supporti suoi nomi sono stati
fatti ci sentiamo dopo che stiamo
lottando e atac sia finito scusami
ciao un occhio l'amore faccia lei se lo
ricorda chiamami grande tutto profuma
voleva 6 con grande tu sei il mio curdo
vieni qui dice bravo ma scusa ma
staccargli quel corso di mandato
rimane ancora io sono il video maker o
che abbia aperto apposta vermone si
immaginava guarda se non ero certo
indiana trial e cena che mi sa che alla
prima classe e uno sballo saprà molto ed
arance bicchiere di cristallo ma guarda
manca educato insomma la carità
già ma chi sei e ti accompagni stai
[Musica]
senti quel che volevo fare due cose 1
che cos'è il nostro locale si chiama ex
galleria
guarda questo era il nostro siamo qui
il tuo coop per questo ma è un problema
perché lo vedevo bene tutti coppie di
tutte quelle con cui sono stato qui ti
richiamo in un momento diverso perché
sto girando adesso va bene ciao ciao
regalato guarda miliardaria a uno yacht
di venti e passa metri ma che già dall
isola karate poi essere interessata io
sono sola è interessatissima alle barche
lei che si capisce che è una figlia che
nei cara e 3 ma in realtà tu sei un suo
acquisto è ragazzi mi ha chiesto di
sposarla non volevo che passasse ios e
siccome per la sua ricchezza come sono
fatto strano io mi sono allontanato beh
allora dovrebbero un sacco di trip
cra.na.it aiab e verdier in cammino con
la tua carta di credito la strisciata
sulle sue chiappe la [ __ ] amo secondo
giro altra corsa
c'era una corda non lo ha certo aveva
proposto ma le astemie
margherita margherita vale astemia per
le telecamere prima che io non ti
avrebbe mentito su una cosa del genere
fa secondo cui veramente margherita dei
punto ecco mezza con bugiarda a chi
vuole il secondo giro i caa kabanga
grande a cavallo
aspirano a capalle alle quattro e mezza
questo è un coppia è fatto da te
inventato detto una base di whisky ore
16 e 30 benissimo cugino mica come
affermiamo ma che sto facendo gabriele
benvenuti all'ex gallery sembra di stare
in una madre che siamo scappati da casa
mc beal e invece lo troveranno tecniche
di lotta dalle di più riuscite a vedere
troppo forte siamo mai sentiti occasione
monti scusa ma tu che fai quando
uscivamo qua bene siccome siamo
un'analisi sulla nostra perché sono nati
1994 quadri che ci riconosciamo navi di
tavoli con i molti non riccardo piacere
calorica ma noi conosciamo davvero
al mio amico federico ai giorni vissuti
a rione monti possiamo brindare solo
l'ulteriore monti chiede rione monti
alza il bicchiere al rione arrivano a
quella due settimane vissuto e qua qua
si fanno foto non perché l'hanno
riconosciuto ma perché siamo nel rione
monti e quindi tutti vogliono fare foto
nel rione monti ad una famiglia è la
bellezza del rione monti dell'ex
galleria come si sta entrando mani
grande uomo vedere ogni volta che ci
vado non riesce a staccarsi da me a roma
c'è il papa ea montis e federico mio
amico fraterno siamo così sono commosso
perché è sempre così commentate tutti
con amico fraterno amico fa perno astag
amico fatta la gara sta chiamando sua
madre sotto con dai chicchi o no mamma
allora
giba una bimba che loro dicono che io
non sono matto mia vero mamma mi senti
[Risate]
pronto marche ciao
[Musica]
niente niente sta facendo la scema come
al suo sogno niente praticamente brera
fatto lo share voto non è vero allora
hai presente che marghe io non so dire
bugie ha bevuto nel momento in cui sta
con gabriele ce lo siamo detti e c'è
qualcosa di strano tra loro due un di
impressionare presente pur di fare colpo
chiamo fra due secondi secondo me le
vuole fare colpo sulle telecamere
secondo me la fa ma le ha dato alla
testa
da quando è diventata un'artista nella
mente dell'artista molto parallela
artistico brava margherita brava ci sta
che è natale si stavano per le feste un
bacio siamo tornati a casa io sto
tirando ricoperte di questo letto
ragazzi sta tenendo il blog
ora non voglio essere tragico ma per il
20 cioè era già il 20
fondamentalmente ne mancano 4 se ci
pensate passeremo un natale di
solitudine quindi sicuramente non è che
smetteremo non il blogger schiano questo
finisce a fare insieme ricerca di tranne
dei modi per ingannare questo tempo di
le maggiori delusioni insieme scusate è
finito di fare tutto quanto accendo la
luce magica tmb auguro la buona